today
um what we'll do is um in the first half
of lecture we'll cover essentially the
foundations of autoaggressive models in
the second half of lecture we'll cover
some of the latest advances so this is
the outline for today we're going to
look at autoaggressive models it is one
type of generative model um as you know
we'll cover multiple types of generative
models five different types in the first
five main lectures of this course this
is one of five um has many advantages
actually quite popular these days but
it's not the only one that matters part
of what's interesting about the field is
that it's not so clear you know which
models are going to be ultimately the
most important ones though certainly for
text it seems that this one is you to
stay for at least a little while because
it's doing really really good and also
for images speech is doing quite
good so um but again it's just one of
many and after we've covered all five
five lectures down the line we'll we'll
be able to contrast them a bit more with
each
other so bit of motivation the problems
we'd like to solve are multiple we' like
to train a model that can generate data
meaning we have a data set that already
has data but we' like to train a model
that we can ask to generate data that is
similar to the data that's already in
the data set um this could be
synthesized new images synthesized video
synthesized speech text and so
forth we'd like to be able to compress
data um if we build a good probabilistic
model of our data distribution we know
from information theory that if we have
a really good model we can use that to
achieve the optimal compression of that
data set and future data that is similar
coming from a similar distribution and
so the better we can model the data
distribution the better we can build a
compressor for our data if we'd like to
in the future and so the more efficient
our codes will
be um another big use case of generative
models is to detect anomalies when you
just build a classifier it'll give you
an answer let's say dog or cat or car
versus pedestrian but if the data is out
of distribution it'll just make its best
guess unless you have special measures
in place to to do more whereas a
generative model can output it
probability of what's on the input under
the effectively model data data
distribution and so when that
probability is very low you know this is
out of distribution hence um might be
something where your classifier let's
say is not going to give a very precise
answer we not likely to give a very
precise
answer today we'll look at likelihood
based models we'll look at likelihood
based models depending on how you think
about it um in all five types of models
that we'll cover um but you know some of
the other models can be thought of in
other ways that is sometimes even more
popular to think about them a little
differently but definitely
autoaggressive models are thought of as
likelihood based models in pretty much
every description that uh is out there
so I'd like to estimate the probability
distribution of the
data somehow have that available to us
in a model but we're never going to have
direct access to it we'll just have
samples so that's a problem we'll be
faced with we'll have
effectively um
we'll have samples X1 and so forth to xn
coming from the data distribution and we
hope that they're representative enough
of the data distribution that we can
learn a model that hopefully captures
the data distribution
well that model computationally should
allow us to compute the probability of X
for arbitrary X so you give a new X
maybe it's images that you're training
on you give a new image should able to
compute the probability of that image
under the distribution that you learned
and you should be able to sample after
ask the model to generate a new image in
that case or new text if you train a
text model and so forth today we'll look
at um discrete data this might sound uh
limiting in some way in other ways it
might not sound limiting at all um the
way it could sound limiting is that you
could naturally think of let's say
speech signals and visual signals as
being continuous how intense is the red
green blue value how how much I guess
pressure is there in the air over time
for speech um so in some sense
continuity in that data makes sense to
try to account for but even so with
these models it tends to be discretized
before it's being U modeled and that's
what we'll do in the lecture today now
maybe there's an opportunity there in
the future for you to do autoaggressive
models with directly working in
continuous space it's possible it's not
what's worked well for people so far and
I can give you one reason that this
might be the case um one of the
challenges with continuous data is that
it's easier to go out of distribution
because the space becomes naturally all
of a sudden much bigger and so if you're
trying to generate samples with
continuous data you quickly start
drifting a little bit out of
distribution even more out of
distribution even more whereas discrete
data almost is like an automatic error
correction you stay on the discrete set
of points that you're allowed to go on
you don't drift off into continuous
space I'm not saying it's unsolvable and
some people could argue that diffusion
models which we'll cover later kind of
address that problem to force you back
onto the manifold
but at least so far aive models that are
successful tend to model data as
discrete even when it's images or speech
it's turned into discrete data before
it's being uh a model is being trained
on
it so we want estimate distribution of
complex High dimensional data let's
think of a very simple image that
doesn't even feel that large a 128x 128
by3 for red green blue pixel values
image that's roughly a 50-dimensional
space 50,000 numbers between 0 and 255
that you're specifying to specify this
image so even for something that sounds
pretty small actually the reality is
that it's quite High dimensional and so
even though we'll build intuition by
initially looking at onedimensional
distributions we'll have to grow from
there to building things that can handle
High dimensional distributions that are
not even close to onedimensional
we want computational inst statistical
efficiency we want our model to train
efficiently computationally and in terms
of data needs uh the model itself should
also be efficient uh ideally the model
isn't too large because a large model
would more expensive to work with more
expensive to store um obviously the best
models tend to be quite large but you
know you hope that they're not
unnecessarily large you want
expressiveness right you don't just want
a fast model that can't express the
distribution well it's fast but it's
it's useless we want generalization not
just memorization we want good sampling
quality and speed and we want a good
compression rate and
speed so here's how we'll go through
this we'll first look at one-dimensional
distributions then we'll take the step
to high dimensional distributions and
then we'll do a deeper dive into the
current most popular type of
autoaggressive models which are the
causal Mass neural models and pretty
much entire second half of lecture will
be on that but the other models I think
could be relevant in the future future
it can also give us a building block to
understanding the ones that matter the
most today so in the first half we'll
have a broader scope make sure we
understand the foundation second half
we'll go deep on the ones that are most
popular today and at the end we'll say a
little about little bit about some
things that aren't necessarily super
popular today yet or maybe will never be
but you don't know ahead of time that we
still want to make you aware
of okay let's say we just need to model
a onedimensional distribution um maybe
we have a data set and the uh samples
are integers from let's say zero through
100 is what they can be and here's what
our data set looks like that's our train
set we have you know a good fraction
that land around 80 a good fraction that
or clustered around 30 and then it tails
off from there in both cases that's our
data um the model we could use that
we've already drawn up here is histogram
a histogram just effectively counts how
many data points are there of each type
and you just plot it out like we did
here and you say okay the probability of
being the number 40 is essentially
reading it off from that plot about
0.01 4 or something 0.013 something like
that um the number
that
lives essentially right at the 40 Mark
here there's a number here and so that
would be the probability of it being 40
and that's a probability distribution
it's a very simple distribution it
consists of 100 numbers effectively that
each indicate How likely it is to get
that number they add up to one very very
simple easy to execute on um so I guess
for something like this it would be easy
to do so the the downsides will be
different from it being easy or hard to
do um but let's take a look at what it
can do inference if you want to query
the probability for arbitrary uh value I
simply you do a look up in the array
that you have P1 through PK to sample
and I want to be explicit about the
sampling here because this is actually
how everything will sample will end up
like that
so the model has probabilities P1
through PK now you want to sample
something from the model what do you do
well it's easy to sample from the 01
distribution now maybe some
theoreticians will will argue that's
also hard but essentially we assume that
we can sample a random number uniformly
from 01 easily there are random number
generators that do a good job at this
and with access to that we turn that
into a sample from this histogram and
the way we do it is that essentially we
build the cumulative distribution so the
histogram looks something
like this right very rough sketch the
cumulative distribution effectively adds
all that
up something like this I didn't mean it
to overlap but it runs between zero and
one you sample between zero and one some
number if you sample this number you go
here and then this is the corresponding
sample that you get so the 01 lives on
this vertical axis where you sample
uniform from0 0 1 and the cumulative
distribution uh tells you where you land
on in terms of data points um
mathematically you can also say okay you
sample number between zero and one and
then you return the smallest I such that
your random sample is smaller than fi
which is f is the cumulative
distribution number associated with
I by the way when we do the high
dimensional models who sample from them
we effectively will will do the same
thing or maybe you know some tool will
do it under the hood for you but this is
how this is done um in essentially all
cases any questions about this
part okay so we know how to I guess
model a histogram we know how to
evaluate probabilities we know how to um
sample from it that's all good news are
we done um no obviously not um the issue
here is that it often has very poor
generalization all right because every
bin is modeled independently from every
other bin so anything that you learn
about you know the number 40 how
frequently that occurs tells you nothing
about any other number and so if you
have a large possible set of
outcomes well then you're not going to
have much data relative to that set of
outcomes and you have many bins that are
essentially staying empty and you have
no idea if they even should be nonzero
probability or not in this case it's a
relatively low dimens distribution even
so with a good amount of samples from a
low dimensional distribution just 100
possible outcomes um we see already a
pretty big mismatch between train and
test uh distribution which will mean
that the train distribution will not
have that great generalization on onto
test if we just fit the
histogram what can we do that might work
better we could choose a parameterized
curve instead um that essentially
assumes that nearby things might might
be somewhat equally likely 40 is very
likely then 41 might be quite likely too
because they're similar numbers now it
all depends on where these numbers come
from if these numbers come from you have
words in a dictionary you go from the
first word to the second one to the
third one this assumption will likely
not be true but if you think about
pressure in the air for speech or you
think about red green blue pixel values
it is quite likely that you know if a
high red value is likely then a nearby
high red value is probably likely to and
that is what this kind of um essentially
fitted distribution with a
parameterization can give you so the
yellow curve here is maybe what we'd
rather end up with rather than the pure
histogram by the way if you think about
it the histogram fits your training data
more precisely right it's the much more
is the most precise fit you can possibly
get of your training data it's just that
it doesn't generalize well and that's
why we're still thinking about maybe
doing something else like we'd like
maybe to end up with that yellow
curve
so how we're going to do that more
formally and this will translate over to
everything we do later we call that the
G ghost estimate the data
distribution right um from
samples we'll introduce a parameterized
model P Theta P Theta of X and the goal
be to learn a Theta such that P Theta of
X is close to the data distribution
where of course we don't have the data
distribution we just have the samples
from the data
distribution to learn Theta as if you've
done any work in machine learning
recently you might expect we're going to
pose this as an optimization problem
we're going to somehow Define a loss
function that defines distance between
these two distributions and then we're
going to find the Theta that minimizes
the distance the loss that we incur
between these two distributions where we
don't have access to the actual
distribution of course the data
distribution we just have access to the
samples we want the loss function Plus
search procedure to have a few
properties it needs to work with large
data set any is large say millions or
billions of training examples is what we
want it to work with we want a Theta
such that P Theta matches P data closely
um that is the training a must work well
um we need to think of the law
essentially as a distance between
distributions want to get it as close
possible to zero distance um not that
the training procedure can only see the
empirical data distribution not the true
data distribution we want the model to
generalize
the procedure that we'll use in this
lecture and this will change a little
bit in some future lectures though there
will be strong connections um is maximum
likelihood in maximum likelihood the
loss function put forward is essentially
saying that we want to minimize the
negative log likelihood of each data
point
okay so when you have that curve that we
saw the height of that curve essentially
the probability under that distribution
you since you want where there's a lot
of data that curve to be high that want
allocate a lot of higher probability
there and then where there's not a lot
of data allocate low probability that's
essentially what this will do for us um
another way to think of it obviously
flipping the sign we try to maximize the
log probability of our data points so
some of the log probabilities of our
data points so among all choices of the
parameter Theta or parameter Vector
Theta we want to find one that makes our
data most
likely statistics actually tells us that
if our model family is expressive enough
and if enough data is given then solving
this maximum likelihood problem will
yield parameters that generate the data
or data you know very similar to the
data equivalent actually to minimalizing
minimizing the kale Divergence between
the empirical data distribution and the
model so my minimizing this negative log
loss
here is the
same as minimizing the KL between the
empirical data distribution and the
parameterized distribution that is our
model from a compression perspective
what that tells us is that effectively
we're finding the distribution that
allows us to maximally efficiently
compress the data if we wanted to so
that could be an additional motivation
why we would want to do things this way
remember in first we talked about if you
can compress your data well problem
means that you discover patterns in your
data very well so it's a good
representation that you're
learning okay so we have a loss function
we need to optimize it um we're
minimizing an expectation um the
expected negative log probability of our
over our data points um and what
stochastic grm does is instead of
looking at the entire objective in one
go taking the gr then taking a step
it'll look at a subset of the data take
the gr on the subset of the data take a
step and repeat and the reason that
alphone works better is because you look
at a smaller amount of data it requires
less time to compute the gradients on
that and often there's already a lot of
signal you can take that step and then
the next time you look at the next batch
of data you're already in a better spot
before you evaluate the gradient a
second time and so overall you make more
progress that way
then um by doing everything in one big
batch and then taking a step now with
today's compute there's tradeoffs there
I mean theoretically likely it's best to
do one at a time but because of compute
being available to us as parallel
compute rather than uh serial being
equally fast essentially see whatever
fits parallel into your machine that
probably defines your batch size that
all goes in one go and that'll optimize
your walk clock time in terms of how
fast you can you can can optimize it's a
question here and a question there let's
start here why would it be ideal to only
do one at a time if yeah the intuition
of behind doing one at a time if if
let's say you had no paralyzation
available you had to do things serly
anyway is that you land in a better spot
so like once you do a bit of compute you
might as well use the information that
comes from it to get you in a better
spot rather than ignore it till you've
done that bit of compute number of times
equal to data set size and then combine
it all together and do a step and do
your new evaluations of gradients that's
the intuition um I don't know if it's a
hard proof for it but that's the
intuition that most people seem to um
agree upon was there a question over
there yes
I
sure oh good question I should have said
something about that um so K Divergence
measures the
essentially let me just write it out K
this spend be a little thinner let's
see seems
like thick is the way it is okay K
between two distributions let's say p
and Q and let's say it's discret is the
sum over i p i
log Pi I over
Qi and so what's done here is
essentially um this first term
here
is this part it's the bottom part
negative cross P log Q um and then the
entropy corresponds to the top part
that's actually the negative entropy
that's why I need to put a negative in
front of the H negative entropy yeah
thanks for the
question now one thing to note here is
that the entropy of the data here is not
something that has the parameter Theta
in it so you you kind of don't do
anything with it it's more like a mental
construct to show that um minimizing K
Divergence between data distribution and
your parameterized distribution is the
same as minimizing the negative log
likelihood and it can give you intuition
about why it might be a good thing to do
but nothing changes this is just a
constant term no matter what your choice
of of theta
is beauty of Maximum likelihood in SGD
is that it works with large data set
it's compatible with neural networks so
we can do all the things that we want to
do uh a bit later in this lecture
question from
here so the question was if you evaluate
one item at a time in your stochastic
Grand descent would it add more
Randomness absolutely um so you
definitely have to account for that with
things if you were to do that with step
sizing with momentum maybe some other
things um to make sure that you in some
sense maximize The Leverage you get out
of each one at a time versus the noise
may be dominating if you naively do just
one at a time um but yeah with the right
kind of tricks in principle the one at a
time ought to be most efficient
exit once you have paralyzation it's
like batch size equal to where your GPU
can
take yeah what's preventing the model
from not assigning probility to
distribution
points yeah that's a really good
question so why wouldn't it just like
Drive P Theta up everywhere it's
anywhere else yeah anywhere else um
because p D Theta of X over all choices
of X has to sum to one we haven't put
that as an explicit constraint here
we're assuming that the parameterization
we choose is such that every choice of
theta no matter what you choose the sum
of all possible values of X of P Theta X
will be equal to one now if you chose a
model that doesn't have that property it
wouldn't really be a proper distribution
P Theta of X it would be what often is
called Energy based model there you have
to take a lot of care that you don't
just drive ities up in various places
but then forget to drive it down in
other places and uh we won't have a
dedicated lecture to energy based models
but Gans Tado aders networks can be
interpreted as energy based models
here's an example of the training in in
progress It's a mixture of two Logistics
in this case initially or is it three
Logistics maybe even four it um
initially it's not a great fit um but
then over time it starts fitting the
data quite well and you you can see in
the loss here that indeed the loss is
getting better and better over
time so I will say this has fallen a
little bit out of favor lately um using
the mixture of logistics somehow it
seems like the amount of data people
have seems that no a softmax output even
over 30,000 possible outputs the amount
of data seems to somehow cover well
enough that things work out but who
knows this could come back especially
for continuous singles if you want a
strong prior on proximity yes do you
also so good question um the number of
components is effectively a
hyperparameter in your mixture of
logistics um yeah if you're original
data is continuous and you're binning it
then it's also hyper parameter how many
bins you're throwing it into um yeah
those are some choices you might have to
make now it turns out that for most
continuous signals that we think of as
continuous it's actually already B ahead
of time you look look at images they
pixels are B from 0 to
255 uh when you have audio I think it's
maybe you know what is it 24 bit or
something quantization so it's a bit
more than the number of bits in a in a
pixel but it's it's kind of similar
um and so you already have recorded it
digitally so in some sense it's already
done for you you could make it a coarser
binning afterwards maybe if you wanted
to um
yeah yes for the mixture of logistics M
the prev
one yeah like that 0.5 value is that a
hyper parameter like can you make it
bigger yeah good question why is it 0.5
here this is assuming that everything is
integers so this is a specific example
saying if our distribution is integer
numbers from let's say 0 to 100 or 0 to
then we want that bin of width one
associated with each of the integers and
so that's a 0.5 in each Direction I see
so then if you have like fls and stuff
like that then it gets much more
complicated you have Val if you have
floats and that you really want to work
with you might want to work with a real
value um kind of continuous density if
you want to um
or you might end up having this having
discretized already and then you might
end up doing the same thing
um Okay
so we've gone through how to represent a
one-dimensional
distribution we've seen the histogram
approach and how to do it very simple
how to sample from it um we've seen the
mixture of logistics but this could be
other distributions if you want approach
if you have a prior that neighboring
bins probably should have similar
probability values it could uh give a
good
regularizer um but it's all been
onedimensional now we'll go to High
dimensional but as you'll see we'll
build upon what we saw to get the high
dimensional things to
work so challenge with high dimensional
data as we talked about earlier on even
let's say for binary Mist where every
pixel is either 01 28x 28 pixel uh
configuration you have about 10 to the
236 possible images right so if you said
I'm going to naively just flatten this
out think of every possible image as a
possible sample and think of it as like
a 1D distribution with all the possible
samples that could occur you'd have 10
to the 236 possible images um that's
very large like people train on large
data sets but when they say large they
tend to say billions maybe trillions of
examples trillion would be to the power
um 12 so 10 to the 236 is something
completely different um so if you even
just wanted you know a data point
roughly covering every possible bin here
it'd be completely out of scope of
anything that anybody's even considered
doing um today or probably ever I think
number of adoms in the universe is is
far less than that so obviously just
flattening it out is a meaningless
approach to
follow what else can we do well we'll
look at some
Alternatives what we'll cover in this
class is autoaggressive models and here
is where we introduce this notion of an
autoaggressive model um autoaggressive
model essentially models a high
dimensional distribution by modeling a
bunch of low dimensional distributions
in fact by modeling a bunch of
one-dimensional distributions your P
Theta of X where X could be high
dimensional Vector for example 28x 28
image so 28x 28 entries in a single data
point you model it by decomposing into a
product of probabilities of and you you
sequence the pixels in an order let's
say the next pixel given all the
previous
pixels the fact that you can represent a
distribution this way is actually
guaranteed every probability
distribution joint distribution can
represented as in this format in fact
for any ordering you choose of the
variables you can choose an ordering of
the variables whichever one you choose
then you can represent your distribution
as a sequence of conditionals that's
just the chain rule always applies so
we're not making any assumptions here
about our data this is always applicable
if you do it this way it's called an
autoaggressive
model um are we done now that we know we
can essentially just fit a bunch of
onedimensional distributions the answer
is kind of no because it's a
one-dimensional distribution conditioned
on something very high dimensional and
so a conditional with many possible
things you could condition on if you
naively do without a histogram you still
have an exponential blow up in the
number of things you need to count um or
represent so we need to do a bit more
work um to truly be
done there's different solutions people
have proposed we're going to go through
four families of
solutions turns out somehow the third
one that I'm going to present not the
last one the third one is the currently
most of used but that's how logically I
think it works out the best to present
it to you um the first one will just be
a starting point the second one will be
a starting point the third one will be
the one everybody's using today and the
fourth one might or might not be
relevant in the
future Bas Nets you might have heard of
them they're essentially an
autoaggressive model where instead of
conditioning on all the previous
variables every time you condition on
something called the parents of a
variable soste think of the variables as
a sequence of variables like the entries
in the variable as as a sequence you put
them in a directed graph direct directed
a cyclic graph and then you call the
Pars in the graph the things you
condition on and everything else you
ignore so it sparsify heavily instead of
let's say if you have a 100 dimensional
problem variable 100 conditioning on 99
previous variables possible values might
only have one or two parents and so it
becomes a lot lower dimensional to
represent here's a canonical example of
what a Bas net could look like um this
is a baset over five variables b e a j
and M and what you can see is that the
tables associate with each of those
variables only showing four out of five
but um the tables associated with each
of these variables are relatively small
so you could consider just counting
histogram approach to each one of those
um you could also parameterize this um
some Bas Nets use parameterizations is
not very common but it can be done um so
this is a pretty reasonable thing to
do in scenarios like this where there's
essentially some small number of binary
variables that maybe have a causal
structure to them um because this
spcification essentially introduces what
is best thought of as causal assumptions
um if those hold true you're winning by
doing this because you're introducing
real world data structure into your
model it doesn't have to learn it and so
it benefits from having that in there if
that causal structure is not true you're
losing because your will not satisfy the
assumptions it will not be able to
represent your data all that well so in
this case saying that um the structure
in the world is that B and E are
independent variables that you can
sample first when you generate your data
a then only depends on B and E and then
J only depends on a m only depends on a
now if in reality the value of M would
also depend on E directly not just
through what a has become then you can't
capture it you're at a loss and you have
a mismatch between what you learn and
what's in your data um sometimes okay to
have a mismatch you might say I'm
regularizing heavily I'm closing enough
I'm happy with it today's most popular
models are typically not willing to make
this
tradeoff yes is it only an issue if you
leave out puzzle connections rather than
introduce ones that are not that's a
good question if you have extract
connections it doesn't hurt you where
it's going to hurt you is that these
tables are going to become larger if you
use a tabular approach
um in fact the MS will look at very soon
and some can be thought of as Bas Nets
where all the connections are there not
a single connection is removed zero
spars the introduced effectively or
close to zero but then of course we'll
have to do some work to not deal with
tables but something else to represent
those
conditionals yes um when you try to hide
dimensional image do you end up with a
Bas that looks like that or do you end
up with something that is a very T gra
because yeah I think for images this is
just not going to work well um there's
no structure that will really capture it
all that well um but where it could work
better is maybe things like I mean this
example essentially is modeling is from
a actually steart Russell's textbook on
intro to AI you know there could be a
burglary there could be an earthquake
either one of them could trigger the
alarm when the alarm goes then uh either
your neighbor John or your neighbor Mary
could could hear alarm and could then
give you a call to let you know that
your alarm is going off and maybe you
should kind of go home check what's
going on or maybe call the police or
something um that's the model that is
under here and I think with that kind of
storyline this model can can make sense
but you could also then even then argue
things like well if it's caused by an
earthquake probably Mary's busy like
doing other things rather than um
calling you cuz probably in her house a
lot of stuff has fallen and needs to be
you know picked up and cleaned up
or you know she might be like well if
it's an earthquake I'm not going to call
you because you know it's an earthquake
and you know it is what it is everybody
knows it was an earthquake so I mean
it's still even in that simple story
it's a quite a crude approximation
imagine think about like a 28 by or 128
by 128 image saying that this pixel
value here doesn't depend on the ones up
there only through the ones that are
here it just it's going to be a disaster
to uh to assume that yes so the like the
primary reason this is not being used is
that uh we do not know the structure
like very reliably like we don't know if
the missing connections and and the
modality to I would yeah there's two
reasons you might not want to use this
one is that you don't know the structure
possibly the other one is that there
just is no structure that the reality is
that there's just no such structure at
all and so the best structure is to keep
all the edges have a densely connected
graph effectively and and then
effectively you don't have any benefits
of using a baset
anymore great questions by the way thank
you all so Bas nuts very efficient but
too strong an assumption in most cases
leads to poor fits of your data
especially if you're modeling let's say
sequences of tokens or text or images or
video and so forth um the reason I want
to present is because it does exist out
there it's very related to everything
else we're going to see and also it
could make a comeback someday it could
be that at some point maybe people model
more high level variables are worried
about that like very high level
conceptual variables where there's only
maybe 20 variables to worry about and
maybe at those levels of exraction it
starts making sense to have a sparer
model but for Pixel level or token level
text it probably will not make sense um
anytime sooner or
ever so we'll switch to solution
two
MA you might never have heard of maid
even if you're working on autogr and
models all day every day yourself as a
PhD student but I think it's the first
paper that kind of introduces this idea
that is driving everything today so I
want to give credit to the researchers
who did this as well as explain it
because it is the foundation of
everything that's happening now
okay here's a picture from the made
paper at the time it was popular to try
to do representation learning with Auto
encoders and we'll look at Auto encoders
in a few
lectures suffice it to say for this
purpose here is that you have some input
variables X1 X2 X3 that's one data point
consisting of three
dimensions let's say a three pixel image
it's just to fit on the slide it's not a
real image obviously in that
case and what you would do is you try to
somehow with the neural network get a
new representation out and the way it
would be done is you put noise on the X1
X2 X3 and then try have the neural net
den noise it huh like a diffusion model
exactly a diffusion model effectively
but that's the context in which this
model model effectively originated that
was popular at the time around
2015 so this Auto
encoder does not output probabilities it
just when you put in data it'll turn it
into a cleaned up data point if you put
in noise maybe it'll put turn it into a
data point but it doesn't output
probabilities you can't put in an actual
data point and say what's the
probability of this data point you
can't correctly sample from it either
the way this is set up so what what
change that they made at the time is
with may they said hey we got to turn it
into essentially a chain rule version of
this where when I generate a cleaned up
version of
X2 it cannot depend on anything because
that's my first variable in the sequence
they sequenced did in this case
X2 followed by
X3 followed by X1 as you can see at the
top here right it's px2 PX3 given X2
then X1 given X to X3 and they said
instead of using the full neural net
which would violate some of the
assumptions because for example X3 can
only depend on x2 not on X1 we need to
cut out some edges such that what I come
up here with my distribution for X3
given X2 really doesn't depend on X1 and
definitely shouldn't depend on X3 I
can't take a look at X3 to generate that
that would be completely cheating you
just copy it over you'd learn nothing in
your model this way this way this way
this way then this
way and that's all we got that's the
only path leading into X3 given X2 what
is sitting up here this is a soft Max so
a soft Max of x3 given X2 so it's a
essentially a bunch of numbers that sum
to one is being output there and then
you can sample from that or you can
evaluate the probability of that X3
given the X2 you've had so far so that
is the set up for
ma it feels pretty messy presented this
way but I wanted to do it because that's
how it's presented in the paper and
that's how you can go see in the paper
how it's done coule things to think
about is these nodes here don't don't
have to be just single variable nodes
this could be a high dimensional uh node
that has I don't know 128 dimensional
250 1,24 whatever you want to put here
this could be a high dimensional thing
because this could be essentially a full
multi-layer perceptron node sitting
there could be other things sitting
there but the key is that the structure
is going that way
and so going from how MA presents it to
how it's typically presented today this
slide shows you how typically people
would draw it today you have the input
sequence at the bottom you have the
predictions at the top you have a causal
Mass structure running left to right you
see the top is shifted by one it makes a
little easier to kind of cleanly draw
that CM Mass structure sometimes it's
not drawn that way but um often it is
done the way I'm showing it
here so that's made interestingly it's
also every one of today's models pretty
much you just need to fill in more
details on top of this yes are the
connections being masked is that so when
when I'm talking about masking it's the
connections that are not there anymore
so in principle if you had a more dense
neural network there could be other
connections that run right to left
there's no right to left connections
anywhere at then St Network could have
those but then we're violating the chain
Ru property that we want to satisfy to
get a proper distribution representation
so that's why we need to run in this
case left to right um to get that yes
when
you a similar idea to drop out when you
change the the masking effectively
change the order of the variables
throughout your say your EPO um it's a
bit like Drop Out you try to somehow get
some parameter sharing going between
different representations of your data
now of course of course if your data has
a natural sequence to it reordering it
and hoping that that will actually be
meaningful might not be a good thing you
might rather regularize in a good way
you might actually like make it harder
to learn the pattern but if you had just
um I guess I don't know some some data
points that have no natural sequence to
them um then it could make sense to run
this in different orderings through the
same net and effec of do Dropout that
attains the autoaggressive ordering for
your order of choice at any given
time yes the
original make the Assumption of
acyclical or did we just really do a
full
complete um it was always a cyclical it
was all set up as a feed forward NE
Network it was just not set up as a um
chain roll satisfying feed forward
Network so I think yeah you can have a
cyclical graph which has other
complications then you have feed forward
Network which is most commonly used and
then you can do causal masking to get
the models that we have here so you
actually get a probability distribution
out this actually goes back to an early
question somebody asked oh how do we
know that it's not going to pull up P
Theta of X very high in all kinds of
places because we're forcing it to sum
to one and the way we're doing is by
forcing it to satisfy the chain rule the
distribution represent satisfies the
chain rule the if you want to evaluate
the probability of a specific data
sequence X1 X2 X3 X4 X5 we can just feed
that in and we look at the soft Max
reading that comes out on the top and we
fill in the values and we look up the
corresponding soft Max probability value
and that we multiply them together
across 1 2 3 four and five that's going
to be the correct probability under our
model of that specific data point and
we're can do that for every data point
that's possible even for things that are
not data points that we can feed in and
it'll all add up to one if we enumerate
all possible Val values in reality we're
not going to enumerate all possible
values um because that's too many it's
not practical but we know by the way we
Define the new net structure that we're
satisfying the chain rule hence it will
sum up to one you can have this like
just inflate everything kind of learning
happening
yes yeah and then one way to think of
this and that's also why I want to
introduce the baset notion is that it's
a BAS net where that has the maximum
number of edges right you can have more
edges than here every variable has an
edge to everyone variable that comes
after it that's the maximum number of
edges you can have and that's what's
present here we'll sparsify this a tiny
bit in what comes and we'll do some
other tricks to make this more learnable
but um yeah you can still think of it as
a Bas net if you want though very few
people if you let's say say oh is GPT 4
is it a Bas net very few people would
say say it's a Bas n though in principle
I guess you could definitely say it
that's part of the perspective I also
want to give here very special kind of
Bas on a special kind of structure but
yeah was there a question there I was
ask can do this as kind of a markof
process right like is this a mark
assumption you can only get influ by
that right you or no you don't have
connection for example
eachers
um yeah I mean you you can let's not
worry about the details of skip
connections or not just what what really
matters is that it's up and to the right
um You can add Skip connections if you
want in some sense that is
um it that's some some expressiveness
you can add in the what's happening you
could also blow these nodes up and make
them much more expressive you can do all
kinds of things with the nodes
themselves um yeah a lot of options
that's what Wilson will talk about in
the second half is essentially all the
options of what you can put in there and
which ones tend to work well for what
kind of data so it is very important but
I saying this picture let's not worry
about it we'll worry about it in a
second half lecture the whole
time yeah but you need to satisfy that
ordering assumption that's the one thing
you cannot violate otherwise you don't
end up with a proper
distribution
Okay so
how well does this work you can run this
on amnest I'm showing here the actual
amest data binarized amnest data some
some examples from the data set it's a
digit data set um original is grayscale
but you can turn it to 01 images and
then you could train a ma model on this
and let's see what happens this is made
on mnist through 19 EPO initially when
you sample from it it clearly doesn't
generate uh very natural looking digits
or digits at all but as it trains longer
longer and longer and longer it does
generate things that look more and more
like
digits um this is an evaluation from the
paper they looked at different number of
hidden layers see how that helps they
also looked at having multiple orderings
in the training where you don't always
use the same ordering see if that helps
um in this case negative log prop you're
minimizing that so the lower the better
so it turns out using multiple orderings
does help a little bit in somehow
internalizing more about this this data
distribution um another thing that did
in the paper and is interesting to do
with all your generative models is
generate images and then look up the
nearest Neighbors in your data set and
you might say well those nearest
neighbors aren't exact matches and
that's exactly actually what you want
you don't want them to be exact matches
if your nearest neighbors are exact
matches it means that it just memorized
entries in the data set rather than
Having learned a general concept of how
to generate examples that are similar to
the data set
so this is a good thing that it's not
perfectly matched you probably would
want it to be a little closer matched
than it is here if you had a real good
model that was train on this data and
had you know really captur what it means
to be a digit but it is a good thing
that it's not perfectly matched in fact
it's always what people ask right you
have a new when somebody generates some
beautiful art with an AI system it's
like well was it in the data or did AI
actually come up with this and you need
to go do a nearest neighbor look up on
the training data to know whether the AI
was creative and generated something
interesting new or just had memorized
something cool that it now just spit
back
out um you can change the ordering so
here they did random permutation even
then odd raster scan that's like top
left to right going down that's the most
natural one probably that you would
think of uh go columnwise top to Middle
bottom to Middle um so you see that the
ordering does matter a little bit in the
quality of sample you get interestingly
the log loss is about the same for all
of these so what this is showing is that
somehow log loss at least in this regime
is not perfectly representative of
whether it looks qualitatively correct
to us so we would I think most of us
would say that the ones you know the
third and the fourth one maybe the fifth
one look better than the first and the
second one but the log loss doesn't say
so log loss says it's about the same and
that's actually often the case
especially when your Generations are
still quite far from being really good
the log loss can be quite um
inconsistent with Which models are
qualitatively better looking or Worse
looking um it often correlates better
once you're in the regime of very good
models here they looked at how many
different masks should you use during
training um too many different masks
makes it too hard to fit the data too
much sharing of parameters effectively
across many possible orderings looks
like 67 masks was the right way to
regularize in this uh this
case Okay that was made that's
effectively what's being used today
except that it's missing a lot of the
tricks that matter yes conely how do you
sample an image from this do you do like
noise for X1 and then sample from each
of the individual distribs one time
correct so the way you sample is X on X1
you will have a soft Max that is
conditioned on nothing you have
unconditional generation you just sample
from that soft Max you feed it into the
network then you'll get on the output
you'll get a softmax output for X2
you'll sample from that you feed that
sample also into the input now X1 and X2
are fed in together you'll follow the
path to the softmax for X3 you'll sample
X3 and you repeat so you can see it's a
Serial process it's one after the other
after the other um means it can be a
slow sampling process there are tricks
to speed it up but
fundamentally it is has some slowness to
it because it's not parallelizable you
can only start sampling X3 once you have
sampled X1 and X2 and only after that
you can do X4 so there is this serial
character to sampling during training
it's all parallel it's just one forward
pass you do the log prob losses and one
forward backward pass get the gradient
but the during sampling indeed it has
this slowness due to serialization
that's just part of how it's done the
chain R says one has to come after the
other
yes how do youle like how do you know
the ordering of
the yeah so when when in the made paper
they use different orderings what it
means is they start with a densely
connected feed for a network and by
choosing an ordering they remove a bunch
of edges from that densely connected
Network such that the chain rule
ordering is
satisfied for the ordering you chose and
so essentially removing a bunch of edges
then doing a training on that Network
and then when you choose a new ordering
you again start with the dense Network
remove some edges to satisfy the
ordering and repeat that sharing can
also be a burden sometimes it might be
too much sharing at times between the
different um orderings and it might be
hard to learn that we saw in that curve
when is trying to combine so many
different orderings the loss is getting
worse when you have too many different
orderings that you try to squeeze into a
single Network to somehow Master them
all um when you train with multiple
orderings I guess it just has a
regularization effect 6 S8 is the right
amount and
um yeah it's probably just the
regularization that's helping you and at
sampling time you just pick an ordering
you use it to sample and that's it I
think if you want to know the
probability of a sample you probably
just just use all seven orderings and
you take the average log probability of
all seven of them to get a good log
probability estimate of that specific uh
input that you
got yes so because these are discreet
variables you
have
that so the question is do we need to
add noise because they're discrete
variables no we don't need to add any
noise that's not necessary so you just
feed the the DAT
correct so m is expressive but there's
not enough parameter sharing for
efficient learning compared to the
things we'll see now so Cal Mass neural
models those are the winning approach
today they parameterize the conditionals
with the neural net just like made is
still chain rule but parameterized
conditionals with a neural net parameter
sharing across the
conditionals so the conditional used for
XI given XI minus one back all the way
to one is the same s neural network
parameters used for the next one for the
next one the next one it's a repeated
use of the same parameters so it's like
a sliding window in some sense the way
you think of it at the same parameters
are being reused and you also add
coordinate coding um because what if you
do naive made type modeling um you just
don't know where the pixel is located in
the image nothing's telling you that um
if especially once you start sharing
parameters there's no way once you share
parameters that just slide over
everything you have no way of knowing
where you're at in the image so you need
to put that information back in so
instead of having different parameters
for different locations we have the same
parameters for all locations but we
input the location coordinates so I can
learn in the parameters how to account
for
that so picture looks the same it's just
now you get these coordinate codings
being passed in they're not necessarily
are 1 2 3 4 five they can be one hot
encodings they can be relative
coordinate encodings relative to their
neighbors as they're being fed fed into
the next layers there's a lot of details
to choose but at a high level think of
it as it's like a made model but we feed
in the coordinate locations also and
there's parameter
sharing um so let me be very explicit
about that typically and there could be
even more parameter sharing but at the
very least would be that what's
happening
on this Edge over here is the same as
what's happening here and here and here
and here and same for all the other
edges that appear in a similar
configuration but they shifted in time
they'll have the same
parameters and now you can have very
high dimensional data yet a relatively
low amount of parameter still or Alterna
way you can think of it is that each one
of these can become pretty large on its
own because it going be shared anyway so
you have a very large MLP sitting right
there doing a lot of work and that's
possible because you reuse that MLP
layer so many times you get enough data
to train the parameters of that
MLP and then you kind of uniformize it
maybe with with padding
so um you it might actually look like
this possibly in practice where you add
some blanks in the front because if
everything's looking back five locations
then in the front do you want to really
architect your n network to be different
there no probably not um but the front
is kind of a mess doesn't make sense so
you put some blanks and then from there
everything is your actual
data you you would have no loss on on
the blanks
obviously so one of the first models
that did this and did it very
successfully was wave net it did it as a
convolution CU what you saw here
effectively already looks like a
convolution you don't have to do it like
a convolution but that's how it was done
um it was able to generate speech at a
level that was much better than anything
that had been done uh before so it's
really what I just showed you but then
think of this as all 2 by two in this
case convolutional masks don't even look
five back you just look two back that's
it and that's how you uh train your
sequence model
effectively um there was some additional
tricks they introduced because they
wanted to look further back so they use
dilation in their convolutions where
it's not looking back to just the
previous one but it's hopping further
back and so it can learn to take
information from further back the hope
is that the information further back
it's deeper in the network has
summarized what's underneath it and so
you get some kind of abstract version of
what's underneath as a whole taken into
the future and can that way account for
a longer past in a way that hopefully um
is right to be able to to generate the
next uh part of speech doesn't have to
be for speech by the way um can be for
other data too there's also a little
trick um that was used at the time
that's not so popular anymore these days
but I'll point it out here you see this
tan and sigmoid so it's essentially MLP
but then the MLP would um both have a 10
output and in parallel a sigmoid output
and the sigmoid would gate the 10
today's world essentially attenion
models do the gating of the sigmoid is
the same kind of thing it's if the
values are being passed in one thing
then um the key values are doing the
gating of the the key query are doing
the gating of the sigmoid is the same
idea it was just in some the early
version of the same idea that you
compute values that you want to
propagate you also want to compute
something that decides how to gate it or
not gate it and then decides whether or
not to pass something on the reason that
people came out with it back then maybe
slightly different than it is done today
is essentially the thinking was that
Computing a precise value is hard
especially getting something to be zero
if you want nothing to go on nailing
something to zero is very hard with this
t h but if in parallel you have a sigmo
nailing something to zero is easy
because you just drive a sigid very
negative that becomes zero you multiply
it into whatever the t h did you get
your zero out so in some sense the sigo
gives you the power to zero things out
which would be very hard to do with just
the 10 H um where you'd have to so
precisely position your output right
onto the zero uh on the output
wave onnist people didn't do this it's
not a thing to do it was designed for
speech but Wilson did it um made it work
um it looks a bit like made on amnest um
I would argue it actually looks slightly
worse than made on
amist why is that because it's it's a
convolutional character of how it's done
it's lost this notion of location in the
image so we come back to it
we now add coordinate coding every every
entity now knows the coordinates of
where it's located in the image you run
the training that way all of a sudden
things come out the way you hope for and
I would say actually better than the
made results
were so causal Mass neural models um
essentially made but with you know more
parameter sharing that's ultimately what
it is
um add the coordinate coding to make up
for the parameter sharing it's
expressive it's
efficient the question about sampling
remains when you sample you still one at
a time it's going to be a bit slow um
but training is very fast everything's
done in parallel all the losses and all
your um entries in your data can be done
all in parallel if your machine is large
enough you can do one thing everything
in one go um expressive efficient for
training little slow and sampling um any
butts the possible concern is finite
context
window when how far are you really
looking back are you forgetting things
are you trying to process a very large
image do you know the beginning of that
image they really then generate the end
of the image
correctly there are tricks that um allow
you to have very large Windows these
days there is um flash attention bring
attention and so forth that allow you to
get pretty large context and Wilson will
talk about how attention fits into this
um retrieval can help so in some sense
the concern about finite context is
alleviated by finite is actually very
large and you can do retrieval so
effectively you still get everything
that said you could still be concerned
conceptually that finite context is not
what you want if you're conceptually um
bothered by that um maybe it's good to
be bothered by it you could think of
recurrent n Nets as an alternative
solution so they can do infinite look
back in principle was a look CL like um
again this case is Illustrated with um
characters as inputs but essentially you
have input layer a hidden layer and
output layer and what you see here is in
the hidden layer you get this horizontal
propagation which effectively means we
had no horizontals in the previous
models it was all up diagonal up to the
right the horizontal allows you to
remember everything from the past if
your model is large enough you can
effectively put into that middle layer a
compression of everything from the past
that matters for the
future that's the beauty that's the idea
um in
practice does it really remember
everything that's relevant from the past
does back probation give you enough
signal to tease apart what you really
should remember from a thousand a
million a billion steps back not really
and so in practice it doesn't work as
well as you hope for and in practice as
far as I can tell it tends to work worse
than the model we just talked about but
maybe somehow somebody going to get it
to work maybe one of you is going to get
it to work in a way that it does work
really well and I'll make a full
comeback and Wilson will have some hints
on some recent works that are trying to
get this to work that are showing some
signs of
life um run on amnest I think Wilson I
think that was also you um thank you um
with um corate coding again it does
better same thing here um in principle
maybe the memory could remember where
you are by counting you know I'm one
step into it I'm two steps into it maybe
but if you don't force the memory to do
that and you just give it it actually
works better um so might as well give it
to
it um downsides certainly it's
expressive um downsides let me highlight
here not as minable to
paralyzation um with the Cal Mass Ms
that go diagonal off to the right it's
one parallel pass through the network
everything no nobody has to wait for
anybody else one parallel pass through
to do your training with the
horizontal connections everything has to
wait for what came before and the things
that happen at the end will only be able
to happen to do their forward pass once
you made all your way through so much
much slower to train more memory
requirements typically to Trend so a lot
of challenges
there back prep to time as I mentioned
can explo can have exploding or
Vanishing gradients Vanishing meaning
you don't get any signal from the things
that are far away exploding means
somehow it blows up your gradients
become infinity and they become
useless um hard to truly have the signal
propagate right the benefit will be less
than
advertised and it's expressive you think
it's more expressive because this is
horizontal connections but actually
let's take a look at the next slide I'm
going to argue it's actually less
expressive than the causal models that
we've seen before this is a standard CLE
Mass neural model the common models Ed
today and you'd say oh if I have this
horizontal thing in there it's going to
be more expressive but the reality is if
you think about
it you have a certain amount of compute
budget and so you need to kind of map
these to each other and what I'm going
to show to you is a bid hand wve is not
perfectly correct maybe but I think it
gets the intuition across effectively
what the RNN is doing is to restrict
itself to the blue connections which are
the encoder connections the red
connections which are the horizontal
path in the r&m and then the green
connections which are the decoder
connections of the RNN it looks
different in the RNN it gets reshuffled
to look differently but effectively you
think of RNN as a extremely tall CLE
Mass model extremely tall the length of
your data tall CLE Mass model which
typically you wouldn't do that tall that
would be very very tall but make it that
tall and just use the diagonal
effectively and that should show you
that in some sense you're very
restricted in what you're capable of
doing when you're doing an RNN compared
to an actual cosal Mas model um and so
that should concern you and I think if
you do an RNN with that also means that
you probably need a very fancy encoder
that encodes things really well so that
that because you only have that diagonal
available after that that diagonal which
is shared parameters must do all the
work of propagating forward must have
some really meaningful things it can
propagate forward otherwise it's just
not going to
succeed so yeah don't take this picture
to L just be clear I've never seen this
picture before there might be some
intuitions that are a little off in this
picture but I do think think of a RNN as
just a very very extremely tall standard
cosom Mass model as tall as your data
length and only using the diagonal is
more or less correct and can tell you
why maybe it's not the best way to do it
okay um first half of lecture we covered
how to represent High dimensional
distributions in different ways but
especially so using a causal Mass neural
model is a way to represent these
distributions be able to sample from
them and evaluate the probabilities of
new data points that come in what we
haven't looked at is the details of
these neural models and they really
matter to get good performance so that's
what we'll do now
we saw the 1D convolution that was one
detail one specific model that led to
the best uh Speech generation at the
time now several years ago there are
some better ones since then but it's
still a landmark result at the
time how about images
um images convolutions are often coming
in handy to capture the fact that in
images things that are closed together
um might need to be processed together
it's more meaningful and then from there
build out a more Global understanding of
the image um so we can do a c Mass model
hopefully where the connections are
effectively convolutional Connections in
2D instead of 1D um the way you can do
it is is for example all of your
convolutional masks are or convolutional
filters are
3x3 and you mask out the center because
that would pass along the thing that you
are yourself to the end and you can't do
that it has to be ca
um you only leave the entries that are
ahead of you in this case in the top
left to bottom right scan
order um so if those are all the
convolutional filter structures with the
zeros being hard zeros you can change
those um the other entries can be
learned or really this is a mask you
apply to the Learned entries so
everything stays zero in the bottom five
there nothing can propagate in a way
that's disallowed you are applying the
chain rule correctly and and you learn a
causal Mass model that also captures
convolutional structure uh or priors
during the learning process um you can
then sample from
this I thought time was pretty
surprising nobody was really doing it at
the time this first paper called pixel
CNN it's like we're going to generate
images One pixel at a time it's like wow
how does that makes sense but somehow it
kind of just just worked um as I went
through this you can see it's a soft Max
every time you sample from that soft Max
feed it in the sample as the next pixel
repeat and it's a long process to step
through every sampling step and in the
end you get your sampled
image you do get a blind spot in this
case um because if you think about how
that works the the
masking and you reapply the convolution
filter reapply repeatedly if you have a
regular 3x3 you expand in all directions
equally and at the end you have a v um
kind of visual field of your uh
essentially your output can be
determined uh depend on everything but
in this case you can only depend on
things that come before but actually
less than that the things on the top
right are actually not being sucked into
what it's uh looking at which
um can be a problem if in the top R
there's something important for you're
generating at the bottom left you're
just not going to have access to it and
so it limits the expressiveness of what
you can do but upside you have a strong
prior convolutional filters that can
help you um learn
faster there are I should say there are
some solutions to this um we put them in
the appendic this year four years ago
was part of the main lecture the best
models were using this today the best
models are using attention which will
some talk about which is a little easier
to do the masking with without having
the blind spot and so but if you're
curious about doing convolutions and not
having the blind spot check the appendic
of the the slides after lecture and you
can learn about how to circumvent this
but it's very it's difficult to
implement it doesn't feel like it's
exactly right in terms of having the
right prior either and so that's
probably why it's combination of those
two is probably why it's falling out of
favor because the alternative is so much
easier to implement and so it's natural
to go for that if it works well
Wilson right all right see if I can use
this
so I'll help you for a moment so you
have to activate the pen down here on
the
dots turn on the pen and you have to
then use the arrow to go forward and
backward H okay and then I yeah also
recognize his gestures I
see okay all right yeah so I will be
pretty much this next most of this next
half lecture we'll just be about
Transformers uh and attention and and
everything about them and then uh we'll
cover some other stuff at like the very
end so I guess Peter has talked a lot
about Mas convolutions uh made like
masking in the in the weights of the
neural Nets um now we'll talk about
another form of masking which is a lot
more easier to implement and also kind
of understand um in terms of when you
actually like like Implement like a
neural net with this kind of masking so
one of the main problems with like the
com Nets the for wave net the 1D coms
for Pixel C the 2D coms is that the
receptive field will grow like linearly
essentially with the number of layers
that you have so we so that's not
exactly good if you want to learn and
capture like long and dependencies
across like across the image if you're
learning video across time for language
across like long paragraphs so here
comes self attention which has which is
a pretty nice design choice in that it
technically could have an unlimited
receptor field as long as you have like
an unlimited amount compute uh has nice
scaling properties with data so
basically as your sequence Dimension
grows your the number of parameters you
have wouldn't grow so for example if you
had a pixel CNN and you want to train on
larger images then you could grow your
receptor field by growing your the size
of your crownal kernel um but that also
scales with like the the number
parameter scales of the sequence length
or number of pixels which isn't that
ideal and the other really nice thing is
paralyzed with computation which pixel
CNN can do but rnn's cannot um which
makes training like really fast and
efficient okay so this is how scale do
product works so essentially the way I
like to think about it is kind of like a
like kind of like a soft lookup table
essentially so you have three components
to your model you have the queries the
keys and the vectors and then if you
consider like a single query here and
then you can think of your your KV as
like a look up table so you have like
it's like a kind of like a dictionary
like guess like a continuous form of
dictionary so where you have the key
which is a vector and then the value
which is some some other inventing and
then you have that for like for
essentially each token in your sequence
so if you're doing language modeling and
you have like end tokens or nend n words
um then you can you want to tr aend to
for a single query to like which word do
I want to attend to and the way this is
formulated is through kind of like a
softmax structure
so right here
oops
oh soft right here where you can
basically compute similarities through a
DOT product
here of Q transpose K and then the
scaling Factor root D is is not that I
mean it's not that important
theoretically because it's it makes
everything equivalent because it's it's
going to be like canceled out on the
numer denominator
um but it's fairly important for like
stable training um because as like your
Dimensions because if you want to say
scale your model up you might want to
increase the dimensions of Q and K uh
and then basically the variance of that
would also your would also grow with
Dimension D so you kind of want to keep
it relatively controlled regardless of
how you scale your
model um but what you do is you compute
for like one query you compute the
similarity for each key and then you do
a soft Max to normaliz so now you have
essentially like a kind of like a soft
distribution like a soft version of a
one hot distribution where um the prob
where you basically get probabilities uh
for each index and and then it's
reweighted and then basically you
compute the output by reweighting the
the value vectors based on the softnet
result and then down there you have the
here you have the Matrix form of it
which is you have Matrix q k and V are
all L by D so so in this case there's no
batch Dimension so your tension Matrix
which we usually call this is going to
be something like l l by L oops L by L
and then your V is L by D so the result
will be something L by D basically each
query taking like like a a weighted sum
over all the vectors that you can see or
or all the values that you can
see and this is an example of kind of
what we're describing about the
receptive field of self attention so you
have one index here that can attend to
everything in the past or or basically
everything from the prior row and then
and this is not cly Masia so you you can
think of it as like a as as we're not
doing like autograph modeling yet but a
generic Transformer which can widen its
recepted field over the entire sequence
versus for convolution it can only see
like let's say
two like plus or minus two tokens uh
like
nearby
yeah
sh I think is this like supposed to
represent the waiting yeah I I guess it
it could represent the waiting yeah for
coms it' be the like
the the the like the the value of like
the the parameters yeah and of self
intention yeah the attention
soures okay and so in the context of
self attention and how we compute that
using like the attention mechanism is
that I guess the question is where do
the qk and V come from and so the way
the data is propagated is you have like
your input X oh
boy can't write too fast
okay
okay you have your input
X oh I can't go
down all right
okay we're gonna not right for this one
um so you have your input X which is
let's say your your sequence of tokens
or yeah it's kind of like a sequence of
tokens in a language model and as you
propagate it through the network through
your self attention layer is that you
will then apply a learnable weight
Matrix of q k and V to the same X so
then you would basically compute and
then after that you would use that qk
andv and compute your attention and the
output is also something the same shape
as
X so basically you're using your input
so basically the the the everything is
driven by the input data like the keys
and the queries are driven by the input
values and also uh the values the values
themselves as well for V which makes it
really nice because it it can then
essentially
adapt to the to whatever data as input
versus let's say if you learned um like
for convolutions it's kind of like
you're learning a waiting that is fixed
based on the the weights of the
kernels and if we want to so now if we
want to use these attentions and and
learn something that's actually like
autoaggressive then we need to enforce
some sort of a causal mechanism to this
and the really nice thing about
attention is that it's fairly
straightforward if you just look at the
attention mask so if you look at um like
qk transpose here this is basically L by
L
again all right um it's an L by L Matrix
and which basically defines all the
pairwise interactions between every pair
of like like how does uh the zeroth how
does the zeroth index interact with the
zeroth index how does the fourth index
interact with the second uh Fifth and
10th or whatever and then kind of
similar to maid but here you're masking
the attention attention weights is that
you can control the interactions by
essentially bring the the loges down to
minus infinity and so when you do the S
Max The Waiting will be will be zero
basically and The Mask we use here is
generally just called a cal mask it's
like a a lower triangular or it's like a
triangular mask where the the ice index
can only attend to for for for any index
less than equal
essentially that's essentially the
constraint that's being
enforced and then if you implement it I
guess one common way to do it is that um
you take the attention mask for qk
transpose and then you have like a
binary mask which is zeros or ones where
one is like the blue and then zero is
the white and then you just multiply it
by a really large negative number so um
so basically when you do this off Matic
it be something very very close to zero
and it basically be messed out at that
point where is sorry
where where is the weight the we oh oh
sorry it's not there it it should be
there though yeah yeah it should be
outside the sun
Max okay the other really nice thing
about this is that since it's basically
based on the mass the 2D mass that you
construct you can basically construct in
any form you want you can basically
control every parse interaction and then
this also means that you can define
basically any like autoagressive
ordering and then applied as a mask and
then you can just train like that so if
you have like some sort of weird pattern
like this then you can just construct a
mask for that and then it'll be fine and
this is the only thing you have to do
there's nothing else you really need to
worry
about okay and then so now to like the
basically the core architecture of the
Transformers which which uses this
attention so the Transformer essentially
just consists of repeating blocks called
Transformer blocks and then they have
alternating like operations so the first
one is called multihead self attention
which models all of like the pawise
interactions or like the interactions
across the sequence length or across the
tokens and then the MLP which is
basically a standard MLP like a single
layer MLP that um expands like the
hidden Dimension by like a factor of
like four or eight and back then
but that the MLP I guess important to
know is the MLP has no uh like cross
token interactions so what essentially
it does is if your input is like if H
here is
see L by
D then the MLP will just act on this
last HD Dimension
D but then so which essentially it's
just like a like two two two weight two
like multiplications of weight matrices
essentially um and then the self
attention models interactions across
L
oops and then there's some other
architectural designs like they have
like resal connections there and and
some later Norms there's like multiple
kinds of forms but this exact form is
the the more popular one
nowadays
okay and yeah if you just want to Now
train like an auto Progressive
Transformer on these then you just take
your Transformer architecture with the
attention MLP layers and then you apply
your causal mask in the attention layer
and that's basically it um you don't
have to worry about MLP because there's
no cross token interactions there so you
only focus on the attention part when
you want to make sure things are like
okay in terms of not breaking the
autoaggressive property um and then the
way you sample is very similar to let's
say a pixel CNN where you can do four
passes through your model and Sample one
token at a time
sequentially any questions about any of
this yeah I guess
for
um that that is true I guess it's just
one way to model a distribution one way
to factorize it um
and I guess and the really nice thing
about these autog models that they can
model very complex
distributions um but yeah there isn't
anything super inherently
causal of like
like I guess in this case what we're
just considering is a is an image as a
random variable and then we're just
trying to find one one way to model it
yeah yeah so like for example going
on example you to work with videos right
where there is actually caity one at a
time you just treat each frame as a
token as opposed to breaking it up into
CES uh there's many ways to do it uh one
way you could is just you you could just
take each frame you concatenate it and
you do like autoaggressive for every
pixel so you do autoaggressive within
each image and then the next time step
and then you sample each image pixel by
pixel and you do the next time step and
so oh yeah and then one quick thing
about Transformers is that since
attention is kind of like like a
location and variant I guess it kind of
treats everything as like a set there is
no there's no positional information
inherent in position or in uh attention
um there in the very beginning of the
original Transformer you add like like
an embedding that basically tells you
what position it is or or or some kind
of information that tells you
approximately oh this is the zero Index
this is the first second um so then it
knows because maybe that could be useful
if it wants to attend to things like
like if you're predicting text probably
the more of the useful information is
nearby in in in like in in in distance
to like the current word so you might
want to bias like your attention scource
to be higher towards like words that are
one word away two words away three
versus ones that are like a thousand
away okay and I guess a note about
computational scaling which would be
pretty important we'll kind of go back
to this over and over again for the rest
of this lecture um is how it scales so
if you count the the flops of these
Transformers the multi-head ATT tension
uh has roughly is roughly o of d^2 L
plus DL s where D is the H Dimension and
L is like the number of tokens or a
sequence length um and that's pretty
expensive so it's both quadratic and in
D and L and then for the MLP
part um it's o ofd s l it has slightly
more flops in some cases because uh
there's just larger weight Matrix
matrices um but in terms of scaling it's
just uh only quadratic be but what's
really going to bite us is the quadratic
and L in in
attention because we're going to get to
really long sequence links okay so I
guess the next part is now you have this
Transformer and one really nice thing
about these autog of Transformers or
just transformers in general is that
they're very general purpose there isn't
really a strong inductive bias built
into the model if you think of like
CNN's they're built very biased towards
uh let's say like for for images for
modeling images how it's take a CNN and
model text um and these can model really
complex distributions basically as long
as you can find some way to to make your
data discrete then you can um apply the
Transformer do a soft Max predict and
model like model and Sample pretty
complex things so how exactly do we
tokenize so for text there's many many
ways you could do it you could do
characters I think which G had for is AR
an example uh then your the size of your
vocabulary would be like uh like 26 and
then um but the issue is that you or
maybe more if you want do other
languages um but the issue is that you
then have a very you could have a very
large number of tokens um because maybe
each word has an average like four to
six characters and if you have like a
thousand words then it could be like
four to 6,000 tokens already ver since
it could be a lot more compact if you
just use words so
then could be four to six times smaller
sequence uh and then you would have a
very large vocabulary because now you
have to consider like almost every word
that exists uh but then there's like
also an issue of like what happens if we
introduce a new word then the model just
ignores it I mean it's unclear what what
you'd actually do in that case
um so what people have found to work
best so far and it's currently one of
the most popular ways uh to convert text
into tokens is using B PA and coding
which I'll talk about very briefly here
um and it's kind of something learning
something in between words and
characters where it's kind of like a
process that that goes iteratively where
you you start with every character in
your in your vocabulary and then
depending on how many like how many
merges which is like a hyper parameter
here you just choose let's say like if
you want to Target like a code book size
of like 30,000 40,000 then you choose
that many
merges and what you do is you go through
like your your training Text corpus and
then you you consider every pair of
adjacent tokens and its frequency and
then you you merge the pair that is most
frequent and you add that as like a new
entry inside of your codebook so if you
if you find like AB is a really popular
pairing then you have AV as as your
codebook and it's a new uh token and you
consider that also in in the future
paired mergings after you iterate So
eventually you get a code book with like
a bunch of characters and subwords uh
maybe even some full words that they're
popular like dog or cat could be very
common um but then words like xylophone
might be less common so they could be
broken up into like uh like two halves
essentially so this way you get um it's
kind of like a middle ground you get
roughly one to two tokens per word and
it's also generalizes to novel
combinations of characters um as long as
the original characters like if you only
TR on English and you try to tokenize
like Japanese or Chinese it probably
won't work because that's there's no
mapping there but if you want to come
with like a new English word then that's
okay so I guess so going by this series
of of models that actually use these
tokenizers is I'll briefly talk about
the GPD series
um from one to three and then how that
kind of showed the actual abilities of
now that we can tokenize this text and
we can train it efficiently with
Transformers uh what happens you know
we're just doing unsupervised learning
on text we scale and scale and scale
what what benefits do we get in these
models and so gp1 was a 100 million
primary model so very small by today s
standers um and that their focus was
just pre-training on natural language
and then we want to see how how it does
when we just fine-tune this pre-train
model and the end result was fairly
strong initially um where it just
outperformed so so fine tuning this
generally pre-trained model so this task
agnostic Model outperforms A lot of the
models that were specifically designed
for each task like translation or or QA
summarization um stuff like
that
and for
g52 I mean the question just keep on
keeps on going like what happens if we
have more data what happens if we have a
larger model size
um then what you kind of start seeing is
that these models can start so this is
like a 1.5 billion primary model so once
you keep scaling you kind of see that uh
these models can start doing these tasks
in a zero shot manner so you don't even
need supervised fine tuning you can
basically just kind of prompt your model
with saying like oh summarize this piece
of text and ask to to fill in the rest
of
it just purely from like next token
prediction and it does decent it's still
like underperforms let's say humans for
some of them or even some some fairly
strong baselines um but it was pretty
promising results in terms of you needed
essentially uh no supervised data for
for these
tasks and for gp3 so this is scaling up
to 175 billion parameters and this was I
guess something in between so um pure
zero shot performance uh doesn't improve
as much but the in context learning uh
gets better and better so now you only
need let's say you know uh two to five
examples to to prompt your model with
and then you can ask it to to solve the
task at hand and it it performs quite
well as you increase the number of as
you increase the number of shots or
examples yeah so that was briefly about
language model we'll have a full lecture
on it later on uh later in the semester
um but for now we will move on to images
and how you can tokenize for images
right so what Peter mentioned earlier uh
this lecture was the easiest way to
tokenize you just take the raw pixels
right um you consider each HW uh by
three for rg&b and each of them already
stored as a bite on computers so then
you just model uh
you just model these images with a h by
W by3 and then a vocab size of 255 and
then you just the prediction on
that but the one thing is that this is
like really expensive so if you just
even want Model 64x 64 images it's 12K
tokens if you want to go to 256 it's 96k
which is very very large um especially
because attention scales quadratically
so the number of fls
is really really high and then if you if
you want to like train on 256 even now
uh you probably need
like like tens or like 100 gpus
probably but it is possible just very
difficult but especially if you consider
like back in like 2016 17 um it was
definitely very impossible so this kind
of prompted some work into designing
architectures or Transformers that can
still do attention and attend to most of
the context but with a specific masking
structure so on on the left here you
basically have the standard CLE mask so
you can attend to everything uh
before and then on the the other two is
still kind of like a CLE it still
follows the autog of property because
there's no like like blue uh blue tokens
in the top right but some of the ones in
the bottom left are are just masked out
also
and you you can technically train Auto
like a like a full Transformer with this
mask appli it just be really efficient
or or really inefficient um because
you're doing a lot of like dumb
computation because you're essentially
like ideally you only want to do
computation or dot products where uh the
mask is one so where where the stuff is
not being mased out essentially uh and
in the case where stuff is being mased
out you just don't want that computation
to begin with because it's going to be
zero anyways so there's not much Point
um so this paper as far as Transformer
kind of focus on this was kind of like a
engineering Hardware project where they
design Cuda kernels for sparse moles so
they design these sparse masks and then
you can efficiently do these so I think
instead of n s or L squ it's something
like l l log n or l l root n in terms of
scaling uh the cost is that you also you
don't get to model all of the par wise
interactions which could be very useful
um but it allows them to at least scale
to Long sequences of in this case long
is like uh 10 or
12K and so yeah at the time it state of
the art results on perplexity or like
the or loss uh and these are the samples
as you can see they're not they're not
very good um can't really tell what what
it is um but yeah that was what it was
like back then yes s in the previous
slide uh what is the blue deep blue
light blue and the green and what other
color I I think they were just trying to
distinguish between certain kinds of um
certain kinds of masking so let's say
the uh I guess deep blue is always there
and then the lighter the slightly
lighter blue is probably some sort of I
think local masking of like the past
like K tokens and then the lighter one
is like um like a strided masking but in
practice the actual mask anything that's
slightly blue is just one anything that
is not blue is just
zero so the main contribution of these
papers is just changing how you
do yeah but also also now like basically
designing code so that it takes
advantage of that hardcoded mask and
doesn't do like computation doesn't have
to
do
yeah so in the fix Transformer it just
seems that it might not be able to
uh or it still tries to capture some of
them because it can attend to like say
the past three tokens but then can
attend to the Past let's say 100 tokens
but in strides of 10 uh and then
hopefully the prior token will be offset
by one so you can kind of like gather
stuff over long Horizon but it's
definitely not as efficient as just full
on
attention okay
and this is another alternative that
also trained on Pixel called igp this
one was more of a focus on
representation learning um but what was
kind of interesting was the way they
they they tokenized the data so instead
of doing um RGB pixels is what they did
was they just took like a data set of
images and then they just took all the
RGB values as like threedimensional
vectors and then they they cluster them
with five with K means with uh N9 bit so
512 possible means um to to Cluster all
of these colors to find basically the
the modes of the most common colors in
the data
set and this is roughly a 3X reduction
in sequence length because now instead
of having RGB as three separate tokens
you just have uh one token from value
zero to uh like 5 511
um which which is nice and but the main
thing about this paper was It was kind
of one of the first papers that showed
pretty strong representation on results
uh using these Auto regressive models on
images so they train on pretty small
images 32x 32 or 64x 64 and then they
essentially um show some cool results
that as you scale as you scale these
models and then you you take the
representations and you do like
fine-tuning or or do a linear Probe on
them for imag net or or these data sets
uh you can get results comparable to
like some of the popular self supervised
learning Methods at the time um the main
caveat might be these methods are or
like GP l in this case is pretty big I
think it was like 1 point something
billion parameters versus Sim clear I I
believe should have been a lot
smaller okay
so yeah so a lot of these past Works
have done just treating each pixel as a
token um is there a way we can get
better tokens for images and turns out
there is a pretty good way that people
have been using for a while is you just
learn a discrete Auto encoder so if
you're not familiar with what like a
generic Auto encoder is it's basically
just um a model that will let's say for
images it'll take your input image and
then it will down sample it through some
process maybe a bunch of convolutions uh
striding so on into some sort of
bottleneck Z so Z ideally would be a
dimensionality a lot smaller than the
original X so let's say a 256 by 256
image maybe we want to compress it down
to like 16 x 16 or 8 by8 or something
and and then after that you decode it
through some sort of upsampling
techniques uh and then you just train it
with like a reconstruction loss mean
error um something like that and the
important part is that for Transformers
We want at least for autog Transformers
We ideally want the data to be discret
so we want this encoding Z to also be
discret
and there's we won't really cover them
right now um but there's a lot of
methods in the past few years that have
been used to learn dist representations
so Gumble softb and concrete
distribution the same thing it's
basically like a discrete vae um this is
what they also used as the autom encoder
for Dolly I believe um VQ Vector
quantization VQ vae VQ Gan stuff like
that is was fairly popular uh a few
years back and then
um and then the most recent that we've
uh seen is something called finite
scalar quantization or Lial fre
quantization um which maybe in the past
year has probably started to to more
traction as as people have written
papers about it um but essentially you
can if you're interested you can check
out these papers um but the core idea
here these are all basically these are
all basically ways to learn a a discret
z they're kind of invariant to
architecture so it can be a CN CNN
encoder decoder uh but the quantization
part is what these are all covering how
the quantization is done how the
gradients are passed through because if
you just quantize things then there's no
gradients usually um so it's ways to
address this issue address these issues
and one thing to note that's actually
different about let's say like for
language you have bpe for tokenization
or like you can do it by characters or
by words so those are inherently
lossless algorithms uh so you won't lose
any information about the original text
but since these are Auto encoders that
are trained using neuron Nets and
reconstruction error um they can encode
images uh into or some modality into a
discrete representation um but they are
lossy by Nature so you can basically
kind of control that with how much you
want down sample so this was uh the VQ
Gan paper uh and they encoded at least
for one of the models they encoded 256
resolution images down to uh 16 x 16 so
this is pretty large this is a 34x
compression in terms of bytes from raw
pixels and 768 reduction in sequence
length of Transformers so that makes it
much much more tracable um to train this
is going from like 190k sequence leg
down to like uh like 256 or something um
so it makes it some like so like someone
at only at Google can can train it
versus someone I can train it on like my
GPU
so and the Reconstruction is pretty good
you can these are comparisons with other
Vees of like finer details on like a
squirrel um but it's you have to really
look into it to to see any like really
specific differences um and then you can
control it based on how much so if
you're downsampled only to 32 X 32 then
you could get even better reconstruction
uh or or if you more comput and you can
only train on 64 tokens at a time then
you could try 8 by8 and suffer some
quality and reconstruction error but
then you can then train a Transformer um
to to actually sample like reasonable
images
perhaps so that's basically a hyper
parameter it's a function of like how
much compute you have available and like
how good of images you want to train or
a sample
from and these are some examples of
samples from the vuan I believe this was
like also like text image before it got
super popular so on Coco open images
things a similar data set the
larger starting to actually look like
things which is
nice and this is all not limited to
discret enod not limited images people
have recently done stuff for videos as
research has shifted from images to
videos um a paper called mag viv2 where
they uh you can ignore that the leftmost
one but for for the middle one is
basically a trained Auto coder like with
I believe 3D columns stuff like that
it's like a 3D CNN uh they compared it
to like um popular video codex for
encoding and they also compared certain
properties in terms of uh like the the
compression rate and then how how good
it is um essentially saying that their
model performs very similar to even like
the best video codex and then even
better than a popular one green and bl
yellow
yeah so pretty cool that we're starting
to beat these actual compression of
course there is like if you really want
to like of course in terms of
compression there was also the aspect of
the overhead of storing the original
neuronet but theoretically that could be
advertised if you just encode more and
more videos uh forever
yeah yeah so uh so exactly the same as
in chess so what they did was they uh
they reconstructed they encoded and
decoded uh videos and then they they
paired them up with like the Baseline
and they had they had human Raiders say
which one is better and then from that
you compute the
score yeah and then you can use this
Auto encoder and train an autoaggressive
model this was a recent paper like a
month month ago I forgot uh or maybe a
few weeks ago uh called video poet and
then you can generate some pretty cool
videos of chickens lifting weaves you
know stuff like that always with animals
doing funny things I guess no one ever
has any issue with
that um yeah okay and then so outside of
video generation or image generation or
kind of on a slightly separate vein than
pure generative modeling is kind of the
interesting question of like we have in
context learning for language so we can
prompt it with certain examples um and
then it can it can learn from that so we
can prompt it with like a task we make
up and then the language model can learn
that and then it can perform that task
in uh for future Generations so like
what would the analogous thing be for
images can we do like a visual prompting
and have it learn a visual task and then
it can solve it after that uh so if you
had like let's say you had no
segmentation data at all you had like a
lot of other random visual data and then
you you you curate three examples you
prompt it with three example
segmentations and you prompt it with a
new random image um that' be pretty cool
if the model could solve that as well so
what this paper did was essentially
curate a lot of data on on just
different
types of visual data so videos is a
really easy image like sequential image
data um on the second row hard to see
there's like stuff about rotations
around like a like 3D rotations around
objects
um uh doing things in different
viewpoints uh a lot of pair data so any
sort of image to image task so if you
can do pose detection
segmentation uh you can kind like object
detection is kind of image to image if
you have the original image and the
image with the bounding boxes over left
um depth like Optical flow depth all
that stuff
um segmentation masks basically curating
a bunch of data and also segmentations
for videos stuff like that um so about
yeah 50 data sets 40 420 billion tokens
and then you just you just combine it
all into one data set mix it and then
you just train a big uh autoagressive
Transformer on it um and then what
happens so you can get kind of these
neat uh in context learning so in blue
is what is conditioned on so that is uh
not generated so it's given by the user
so this is kind of like a task of like
key points on an object I guess um as it
rotates and then you prompt it with
essentially a a new like a novel object
and then ask it to to create the rest of
it so I guess this was demonstrating
task compositionality because I guess
there were 3D rotation data there were
key there's key Point data and now it's
like can you do it both
together and then you can do other
things you can try identify patterns so
first one is like person getting more
sad and then person getting more happy
or smiley face um things that are like
increasing in number um and the last one
I believe it's like kind of like paired
so it's like
a is it
you know what I I don't know what the
last one
is um oh wait maybe it's getting more
and more dark I see yeah okay
yeah yeah and then aside from that uh
you can basically this tokenization
strategy of learning like the three Auto
encoders can extend to almost any
modality so for audio you just train a
des uh a on the bottom half you just
train a discret auto encoder and then
you do an auto Transformer um in this
case also condition on text but it's
basically all the
same and yeah so like I mean so now if
you can do this for any individual
modality it there's nothing really
stopping you from combining everything
throwing into one giant model and just
train on all of it um so this was for
for video poet they just trained an LM
on a bunch of different conditioning so
you can see they condition on text uh
they condition on images and video uh
with with like a video tokenizer and
then they condition audio with like an
audio kind of like tokenizer um and then
the really nice thing is that this
Transformer is kind of generic enough in
which um at least the parameters in the
video po llm are shared across every
modality um there are some t there are
some modality specific ones like the the
T5 encoder is like parameters purly for
the Tex probably Frozen though uh the
magnet V2 is also Frozen purely is done
to encode video same thing with audio
but but once they enter and get
concatenated to the Transformer those
parameters are all shared across every
modality and it just learns to to model
all of it um together in this case
basically to predict both uh video and
or
audio so pretty
cool yeah okay and then the last thing
for these Transformers to talk about is
related to
caching
so the standard way or the the most
naive way to do the sampling is let's
say you start with your input so you
have two tokens already generated X1 and
X2 and then you want to generate X3 so
what happens is that so this is like
basically you can think one one
attention layer there'll be many staff
but for Simplicity I'll just have one
layer here and then there'll be more
computation that will not include so you
compute uh keys and values for all of
the the prior tokens as well as the Q
for the current one you do
attention and then you you feed it down
maybe more tension layers and eventually
you output uh a sopt Max distribution
than you sample and so you get
X3 and then you add X3 you do the same
thing you compute all the keys and
values the queries you apply your
attention
uh you follow down the Network in Sample
X4 and then you keep
going and then you have
X5 so uh the annoying thing is that you
have to compute the KVs like like even
if I'm sampling the the 10th time step
you have to compute all the KVs for uh
all the prior time steps which also
means that you have to run X1 X2 X3 X4
and so on all through the entire
Transformer Network um so it makes it
very expensive so it makes it every
sampl pass is a full is a full forward
pass of the Transformer so it's
basically uh like in this case for
attention if you like l s operations uh
when in theory we we shouldn't need to
um because if you think about like the
four path for a Transformer a single for
path computes every conditional
distribution which in total is is L sore
flops or or something like that um so in
theory each shling step should only be o
of
L and the way we do that is just we cach
the ks and V's as we sample sequentially
so same starting point with
x1x2 you compute KS and V's initially
you do your Q you sample and then and
then basically the difference here is
that when you computed the KV here
before you just throw them out so
they'll be collected by the garbage
collector uh and then you'd have to
recompute them so in this case you would
have to explicitly store so you have to
like have some code that explicitly
stores this tensor inside of your inside
of your memory
and keeps it persistent as you sample
the next token to next
tokens so you keep K1 uh V1 K2 V2 then
you X3 computes the new K3 V3 which
obviously hasn't been computed yet
because it's a new token and you compute
Q3 you do your attention uh in this case
what you would do is you would take your
K3 V3 and then you would concatenate it
to your cach so now your cache contains
K1 to uh K3 V1 to V3 do your standard
attention and then you sample
X4 uh so now you have your cache from K1
to
K3 you compute K4 you would then
concatenate it uh do a
tension and and yeah and then you do
this for however long however however
long you want to
sample so the main cost here is that
you're trading off essentially uh
potentially in some sense uh like GPU
memory for Speed because this one you
have to cache like if your Transformer
has like uh 10 attention layers you have
to cach these KVs for every single
attention layer uh which could get
expensive you have really long sequence
lengths or um if you have a really big
model so on but it's like very worth it
because it it brings your sampling from
o of L squ uh down to O of L per per
step so then for the entire uh the
entire sampling scheme it would be like
naive sampling would be o of L cubed and
caching would just be o l
s cool any questions about
this all
right cool okay yeah so that was most of
it on the main core stuff regarding
Transformers and then
there's I guess this last section is
some other stuff um that not core but we
thought would also be very good to um to
know or at least be aware
of especially recent developments so one
of the things that I didn't fully cover
was
was basically what I first covered was
the predominant approach to training
Transformers so you can think of like
chat GPT open I like bar or Gemini are
all trained called decoder only models
so it's a single causely Mass
Transformer versus the original
attention is all you need
paper uh that introduce the Transformer
use a different architecture called the
encoder decoder architecture which is
very similar so here I have the I have
the decoder only here so you just have
the attention Follow by fe4 alternating
all cly masked and so on so this is a
standard Transformer we've been covering
um with the only add of thing is that
they have a separate transformer called
which is the encoder which would in this
case the encoder is not mass So it's b
directional so it would encode whatever
input you have um and then the decoder
on the right side would then condition
on the output of the encoder and the way
it's conditioned or the way information
is shared here is just through cross
detention so the the the right half
would attend would cross attend to the
the output of the left half
and and in general this is a pretty good
architecture for in the case where you
have a very clear conditional
distribution of model so in in some
sense a very clear input output so for
machine translation you have your source
and target language uh text image
generation is text and image image
captioning is input is image output is
text uh input is video output is text
summarization input and output V text
but very clearly structured in some way
um um so in that case the these models
work pretty well it just doesn't work
well for let's say let's say Chad GPT
style where you don't even know like or
chat style models where you just don't
know like what is input what is output
kind of like everything like input will
be out or output will be input
eventually as you sample the model so it
makes it really hard to structure an
architecture like this um but in general
these models are still not as used but
kind of used um T5 is a very popular
text model that was used and also
success with that
um uh party is a text image generation
model um and poly is like an image to
text generation models um in terms of
scaling I think they both scale fairly
similarly um but at least from what I've
seen and papers around that the incoder
decoder models still seem to learn
better representations or at least ones
that are
easier to use so for example a lot of uh
text to image or text to video models
would use T5 as an encoder um because
the T5 encoder learns a very good
because it the encoder's job is to
summarize the input text so it's a good
representation for a model to condition
on versus for decoder only it's like the
last layer like you could take the like
the last layer representations but then
that is only used to F the next token so
it could not produce it might not
produce a good representation for like
the entire text as a whole uh and then
you could use middle layers but from
what I've heard it's like kind of hard
to use yeah if encoder decoder is better
then why isn't something GP
uses um oh I think it's it's it's mainly
so in terms of scaling I think they're
pretty similar but for GPT it's kind of
hard to use like it's because like if
you want to use something as a chat
interface it's not clear what the input
output delineation is right um
yeah yeah uh
okay this is party um example of also
scaling these image generation models
using like a encoder decoder more like
this you can see it gets much better as
size increases kind of as
expected okay uh and yeah so one of the
other parts okay so now moving away from
Transformers um last a little bit on
stuff that is not Transformers but still
autoaggressive and things that could be
be more popular recently
yes only model
thats some to space how can use
thater or how is conditioned let's say
you want to do text generation
right let's say have we have
mod yeah you can
so yeah so you can you can embed your
text so the so the output the encoder
will output something like l l byd
representation or like a tensor and then
you have the the the middle block there
is a cross attention so the queries will
be from the decoder hidden States and
then the KV will be from uh the encoder
output so then you would so like the q's
would would attend to the KVs from the
encoder output and that would happen for
every
later
yes yeah I think in the end it depends
on what your use case is if you want to
build like kind of like chat-like models
for example you probably wouldn't want
to use uh encoder uh encoder decoder if
you have very specific tasks you have in
mind like image captioning then um
encoder decode could be useful um but
maybe even decoder only could be okay
yeah I guess I was
ofous youant
model and then you
have dat like how well represent
oh I see
um I think both models would probably be
similar performing it would just depend
on yeah it at that point I think it
depend on how how big your model is kind
of more so invariant to like your
specific
architecture
okay so yeah so moving away from
Transformers let's talk about some of
the Resurgence in current net has been
happening over last year or two um
so we definitely sh that Transformers
can model very comp distributions but
scaling into long sequences which is now
something that everyone kind of wants to
do is very expensive because it's
quadratic um with respect to L and our
prior rnns are are linear with respect
to sequence length um but it's very slow
because when you train it you have to
unroll each time step so unrolling like
200,000 time steps is really painfully
slow um so now the question is like okay
can we still have a recurrent model but
can we compute things in parallel for
more efficient
training and one incarnation of this is
called linear State space models so if
you consider like a a linear State space
model very uh fairly simple so um you
can essentially treat uh X is the hidden
state of your rnm and U here is uh the
input so you can you you can think about
the input to like an attention layer
um and uh and why is your output so it's
basically just doing like a few a few
like multiply by a few matrices and then
multiply by another Matrix and
outputting
it
um there are some specifics about a b
and c here have bars because they're
they're discrete because the underlying
State space model is continuous uh and
there's certain things that are done to
like critize this in a different sense
than what we've been discussing uh or
yeah in slight different sense um but I
guess what's important just consider a b
and c has different matrices so it's all
fully linear so there's no there's no
nonlinear here so I guess that's one of
the key differences with a standard rnm
where you maybe have a t h or something
uh in this case everything is fully
linear and in terms of architecture of
where you actually insert this state
space uh model is that you can think of
it as a replacement for an attention so
the attention is there to model the
temporal temporal dependenc in the Ina
and SSM is just one other way to model
it just ideally more efficiently without
uh suffering like a lot of costs so one
way to parallelize this kind of
model is that you can think about
unrolling the sequence so if you have
your input uh your inputs that your use
at each time step and then how your your
hidden State evolve so x0 uh to X1 to X2
to X3 and so on you're just applying the
uh the first equation here repetitively
and then uh you eventually get certain
factors as you expand out and like
Factor things around and for y it just
looks very similar where you're just
applying a c Matrix as well uh and then
if you do if you write out it most
general form so y k is equal to to to
that uh you can essentially write it as
a convolution because this is
essentially
um kind of like a DOT product I guess uh
is one way to think about it where C A
to the K B and C A to k minus1 b and so
on is is one vector computed from like
your parameters and then your u z U1 U
whatever is the input vector and in this
case it's equivalent to basically a
convolutional kernel uh so you can
rewrite this uh State space unrolling as
a convolutional kernel uh of with a
kernel of length L it's like a one
dimensional kernel of length L which the
I guess the weights are
down so that's one way to compute this
all in
parallel um the other one which I won't
really go in that much detail is you can
also do something called a parallel scan
um which is kind of very simil
algorithmically if you want to think
about how to like if I if I give you
like an array of n n numbers what would
be an efficient way to compute the sum
of it if you had like multi like
multiprocessing available so what you
could do is you can group Pairs and add
them so if you have like 12 numbers you
you group them into six pairs and then
you add them all in parallel and then
and then you you keep doing that in ter
in like in chunks of like Po or two and
then you can then compute the output um
what ends up happening is that both of
these methods are computationally very
similar um at least in terms of sequence
length where they kind of scale off of O
of l l log l so not exactly linear
because the original if you just do a
for a for scan of the or if you do an
unrolling of the original recurrence it
would be o of L um but in this parallel
form since you're taking kind of
advantage of like um for the convolution
you're doing like ffts and stuff for
some things so that's where the L out
comes from um but it's not ideal because
you're like wasting a little bit of
computation um to do this
parallelization okay um I will Zoom
through this uh so another one is linear
tension
uh this is basically like kind of like
the standard tension setup but Rewritten
so in instead of using uh like a soft
MTH you can write in terms of similarity
based on similarity weights where for
attention that is like the similarity we
e to the the do pro over root D um and
this paper was looking at different
kinds of similarity functions
essentially
so you can approximate it just by TR
treating this kind of as like a kernel
uh as like a generic similarity function
so so basically to convert each feature
Vector into its corresponding like
calized higher dimensional feature
version and then so now it's basically
just all purely linear like there's no
nonlinear in here anymore it's just uh
dot product in Matrix mplications uh and
then because of that you can then
reorder some terms around like on the
right so you can bring the Q out and
then you can compute the uh KV transpose
there and
that kind of removes some of the
quadratic um
terms but the really nice thing I guess
is if you look at it in terms of like a
COO model um the sum goes from
originally goes from J is equal to one
to the sequence length n um but if it's
causal you don't want to attend to
anything in the future so now it's from
J is equal to 1 to I so now this is kind
of recurrent because if you want to do
the next time step it's j is equal to 1
to I + 1 and then I Plus so then you as
you sample for this for training you can
still do it fully parallel but as you do
inference here uh your essentially your
recurrence state is the sum of J is
equal to up to your current time step
and then when you want to do the next
time step you just compute the outer
product for the current time step and
then you you you add it um so this also
makes inference very fast for this
case and last thing am I talking about
this or okay I can all right the last
thing is um basically complimentary
ideas to kind of terization uh the main
theme is kind of like learning
hierarchical representations or learning
uh different
factorizations of of these datas so for
example for super
resolution is instead of generating the
entire nness image at a time you can
generate it hierarchically so you
can or in this case you can like yeah
you can you can subsample like the 20 x
20 image into 7 by seven uh pixel grids
and you can chain a pixel CN on that to
generate 7x7 and then you can chain
another pixel CNN that conditions on the
7x7 to predict the 28x
28 in this case it it could be you know
if you only have one GPU available and
you can't fit the entire model maybe you
can break it up into two models uh and
then you can train a better model that
way it could also be a slightly easier
distribution to
model yeah and these are I guess other
examples of other data sets faces
or
uh like the bedroom data set I guess
Elon um you can take it even further by
doing learning different levels of
hierarchies of like representations uh
and then slowly up sampling that way and
you can get eventually to a pretty high
resolution these are still all
autoaggressive but autog have different
levels of representations where you
could potentially like focus more of
your parameters on modeling the lowest
levels of representations where that's
more computationally efficient and then
at the super resolution levels where at
that point it's a much easier task
because most of the image has been
formed just like maybe a little bit
blurry uh it's much easier to fill in
the details that
way uh you can do similar things with
doing gray scale first then color so in
this case this was colored and Mist on
the examples with like the pink and gray
but you can generate the First Column
first of just black and white and then
you can train another pixel CNN that
will condition on the Grays scale
version and generate the colored
version more examples for sear I
think yep I think that's it
then well
[Applause]
yeah